if you played Modern Warfare 2 after its
release in 2009 that is a sound you will
be intimately familiar with it's a sound
that resulted in either the elation of a
kill or in the case of
seventeen-year-old me being shot by
quickscoper 'he's quickscoping the
bizarre trickshot that modern warfare 2
players would spend hours perfecting is
one of the things that the intervention
is most well known for it went from an
unknown weapon in the real world to a
digital firearm capable of seemingly
impossible feats of sniping packaged up
with an iconic sound that even now can
trigger nostalgia in any veteran first
person shooter player manufactured by
shaked at USA the m200 intervention
first entered production in 2001 and it
quickly starts to win records for its
accuracy even making headlines in 2017
when an SAS soldier used it to make a
shot from over 1.5 miles away but it
wasn't just its accuracy that makes it
notable one of its most distinctive
visual features is that the carry handle
is placed below the main body which
basically means that you're carrying the
thing upside down a strange change to be
sure but an important one as the rifle
weighs a whopping 29 pounds or just over
13 kilos which is certainly not the way
it's represented in the multiplayer
lobbies of Call of Duty the intervention
is a young and relatively unknown weapon
there's no real history to speak of and
as such just doesn't have the legacy of
many of the iconic arms that remain stay
in our shooter games it didn't help that
the first game the rifle featured in was
2004 sold in the secret Wars a title
that was marred by bug emissions and
received middling reviews another place
you may recognise it from is in the
hands of Marky Mark warbirds Bob Lee
swagger from 2007 shooter
while it's presents on the silver screen
in this sniping action-thriller help to
give the intervention a little more time
than limelight
aired with the rifles explosion on to
the brand spanking new HD TVs where the
weapon finally got the attention it
deserved after Call of Duty broke away
from the world war 2 setting with the
modern warfare series the new modern
backdrop proved to be an immediate hit
with fans and critics alike bringing
with it a new style of game that was
foreign to longtime Call of Duty players
as well as an armory of New Age weapons
to play with chief among them the
intervention first appearing in call of
duty modern warfare 2 the modern frame
and design of the intervention made a
perfect fit for the franchise and made
for a great addition to the game whether
it was in the hands of SES as Captain
Price or xxx bong Ripper 69 online the
intervention was instantly a hit with
the game's multiplayer mode with the
weapon developing a lasting popularity
and reputation due to being one of the
most used guns in the game as well as
being so prominent in the slew of shared
content that dominated the web between
2009 and 2012 classics such as mum get
the camera or the magnum opus best
trickshot reaction ever by the one and
only eye trickshots
HDX can you imagine where these kids are
now 2009 s Modern Warfare 2 was a huge
success and catapulted not only the
intervention but the phenomenon of quick
scoping and trick shutting into the
spotlight through the incredible
popularity of both the game and the
strange ways players were using the
rifle the intervention would become an
instantly recognizable and iconic weapon
in the FPS genre the intervention would
appear in other games like ARMA 3
battlefield 4 and sniper ghost Warrior
but in the years since modern warfare 2
the weapon has also made an appearance
in one form or another in Call of Duty
online infinite warfare and modern
warfare remastered a version of the
beloved intervention even featured in
Call of Duty mobile and through feats of
dexterity I can only hope to achieve
there are folks out there Landing trick
shots on their phone what made the
intervention a cult hit among FPS
players was unlike guns like the ak-47
which has been around since the 40s the
intervention was a relatively new gun
and that made interesting in many ways
that helped
the modern in modern warfare many of the
other weapons in modern warfare 2 had
been seen before in some form or another
they were tools that people had already
used or been exposed to in other games
the intervention was relatively speaking
brand new the intervention was also the
only bolt-action sniper rifle to be
featured in create a class in modern
warfare 2 making it further stand out
from the rest of the marksman rifles in
the game and a lot of shooters there's
kind of a misconception that when it
comes to sniper rifles the
semi-automatic ones are faster and
easier to use but cause less damage
while the bolt-action ones are always
slower and have a higher skill ceiling
but are subsequently much more powerful
while many still hold the opinion that
the intervention is superior in
actuality the damage accuracy and
movement speed of the intervention and
the Barrett 50 Cal were the same so that
begs the question why was one so much
more popular than the other a big part
of the interventions appeal was the
sound design associate with both the
rifle and call of duty as a whole the
audible crack as you fired around the
sound it made when you landed a shot and
the oh so pleasant feedback of a
hitmarker all now create a warm feeling
of nostalgia for the iconic rifle sound
effects are a grounding and memorable
force in video games in the same way the
ping of an m1 garand makes me nostalgic
for the world war ii shooters of my
youth the crack of the intervention and
the following sound of a hitmarker will
always summon memories of me playing
modern warfare 2 into the early hours
the hitmarker being such a recognizable
and nostalgic element of its own as also
meant it's been part of the very same
culture that made the intervention as
popular as it is it popularized a
gameplay feature for FPS games to come
as well as being deep enough into Cod
strange mean culture that it wasn't long
until it was a huge feature in parody
montages and even became available as a
bumper sticker the visual and auditory
depiction of the intervention combined
with modern warfare 2's arcade style
shooter mechanics of a mobility
aggression and rapid killstreaks was a
perfect complement to the play style of
speed and powerful sniping this created
the perfect foundation for the players
popularity to skyrocket and over time
the hundreds of thousands of players
that were taking to the battlefields of
favela Skid Row or rust began to find
new ways to make the most of the
interventions unique capabilities you
can't talk about the intervention
without bringing up the bizarre ways the
players flung around their rivals and
took shots that would be impossible in
the real world everyone who's played a
Call of Duty title is familiar with the
term quickscoping whether you're on the
receiving end or dishing out the
punishment
I'll call of g4 and modern warfare 2
popularized the trend of quick scoping
players been toying around with
mechanic's since 2003 in counter-strike
1.6 using the scout rifle or the iconic
AWP would often see players rapidly
scoped in before a deafening bang and
then swaps their knife to cancel the
animation of cycling the next round
the earliest known entry of the term was
an urban dictionary post from 2007 where
a player described the process in
reference to counter-strike but it was
in modern warfare 2 where the trend
really took hold given the speed at
which modern warfare 2 use game play
unfolded learning how to use rifles like
the intervention in a way that allowed
players to be mobile and reactionary was
almost a necessity but what came next
ventures further into the bazaar Call of
Duty became the poster child for those
over-the-top moments in games and the
intervention was the very nail that
poster was hung upon if you were playing
modern warfare 2 shortly after its
release it was a common sight to see a
ghillie suited soldier intervention in
hand jumping off of tall objects while
rotating fast enough you thought they
might actually take off and while they
may not have landed many shots the ones
that made contact would often be smashed
together into montages and crammed into
2010 YouTube's algorithm until any video
game related page was filled with
recommendations of spinning frag videos
trickshotting was a play style that was
adopted to try and add a dose of
creativity style and skill to landing
shots with what was at the time one of
the most popular weapons in all of Call
of Duty there was a fascinating quality
of showmanship to using the technique
and as time went on people would attempt
to pull it off in tense moments as a way
to turn the dynamic of a match on its
head the flashiest Kills they needed the
flashiest of weapons and there could be
no other choice than the intervention a
weapon that was truly starting to take
on a life of its own there was nothing
quite like watching the killcam and
seeing someone land the game-winning
kill by spinning around and casually
firing a bullet into an unsuspecting
enemy in the distance the popularity of
this virtual firearm and the acrobatics
associated with it led to a huge rise in
players creating montages to show off
their very best kills to such an extent
that whole teams and clans began to form
around those videos cutting together
their hottest intervention shots and
tricks one of those clans was phase
phase started life in 2010 as a youtube
channel showcasing the montages and
clips that had been submitted to them
but has since become a massive eSports
organization with dozens of members
competitors and streamers across
multiple games including pub G fortnight
csgo and of course Call of Duty even now
if you go on their channel and saw their
output by oldest their second video ever
was their first dubstep filled sniping
compilation with of course the
intervention but that's not the only
success story that started the glance
down a scope and the pull of a virtual
trigger optic gaming is another large
eSports organization that has their
roots firmly planted in the Call of Duty
subculture of sniping trickshotting and
competitive play if you go back to their
very first video one that is still
listed as their most popular in the
entire history of their channel it takes
just 34 seconds to see the first glimpse
of the intervention now sure these
montages may have aged poorly with
strange contrast color balance and cut
stretched out to fit the pace of
whatever dubstep was thrown over the
clips
[Music]
but the one constant that is still a
pleasure to see today is the oh so
recognizable silhouette of the
intervention whether it be a 360
no-scope a YY a ladder stall or a
throwing knife across the map trick
shots were the hottest thing to show off
your skill or in many cases look
especially if you wanted them to be
accompanied by the feverish screams of
the young or calls for their impressive
feats to be cataloged while
trickshotting may not be as huge today
as it was a few years ago there are
still plenty of talented players out
there that are keen to experiment with
their games and show off their most
bizarre exploits people have even made
their way to the mobile versions of call
of duty to land shots that seemed
impossible on a phone screen and
literally within hours of the new modern
warfare alpha being live there were
trick shots being posted online with
fans pleading to any developer that dare
listen to bring the intervention back
into the spotlight of 2019 while it may
be too early to tell if the new modern
warfare will bring with it a modern
revival of the trick showing phenomenon
the impact of the intervention on gaming
culture is undeniable for a weapon that
isn't even twenty years old has managed
to catch the imagination of both FPS
players old and new we'll always
remember that iconic sound of the
Godfather of quickscoping I hope you
enjoyed this a nostalgic look at a
weapon that absolutely played my teenage
years and definitely caused a broken
through 60 controller or two for more
deep dives just like this one be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss another
episode of loadout